la última hora en ucrania pasa por la
guerra del donbass es ahí donde se están
concentrando todos los combates con
artillería y armas pesadas el ejército
ruso está avanzando muy lentamente y
está también bombardeando las primarias
en las principales vías de comunicación
por donde los ucranianos transportan las
armas pesadas que reciben de sus aliados
de occidente nosotros estamos en jarquín
otro de los frentes abiertos en la zona
noreste y preocupa esta zona porque hay
movimiento de tropas rusas al otro lado
y también porque hace apenas unas horas
han explotado varios contenedores de
gasolina esta ciudad es la segunda
ciudad más importante de ucrania y fue
una de las primeras en ser bombardeadas
ahora mismo hay muchos ciudadanos
atrapados aquí que necesitan asistencia
humanitaria y también muchas personas
que ni siquiera tienen a dónde ir y que
están buscando un refugio desde aquí
también podemos escuchar la artillería
que se encuentra que está ocurriendo
ahora mismo en el frente apenas unos 40
km